les amis la dernière fois que j'ai
convoqué des amis youtuber ça c'est
extrêmement mal passé nous avons échoué
le challenge
savez vous pourquoi nous avons échoué
car un homme ne peut rien faire s'il
n'est pas accompagné d'une femme pour le
soutenir a mis aujourd'hui nouveau
challenge un jeu auquel j'ai joué il ya
quatre ans sur la chaîne youtube cat
mario aujourd'hui ce sont des youtube
buzz qui vont me venir en aide pour
arriver au bout de ce jeu certaines ont
déjà joué à des jeux d'eau un peu moins
ça va être très amusant c'est parti as
tu déjà jouer aux jeux vidéo a bien sûr
tous les soirs à quoi tu joues tous les
soirs tu le relais mario oui j'y ai joué
quand j'étais en scène tu te souviens
bien attention check point du prado je
sais pas ce que c'est d'ailleurs ce
chèque twain tchèque excusez moi c'était
condescendant de gros connard de merde
chaleur non désolé je sais qu'ils me
frapper ces gens là non je trouve que tu
es très fort ouais mais si je t'appelais
pour les branches je dirais peut-être un
peu galéré condescendance et au final tu
m'as vraiment fermer ma gueule tu
appelles quelqu'un quand tu veux
d'accord après il ya juste au dessus du
but à la casse ne pas pouvoir regarder
garde jamais y aller
voilà non imaginons méchant alors ça je
suis désolé un nuage c'est pas méchant
comme ça alors déjà tancé voyager c'est
une dernière fois et après j'ai cherché
une copine ok attention alors oublie pas
il faut apprendre de ses erreurs il faut
pas avancer caprio et la voilà c'est ça
les la donne en gros food saute sur le
cube juste attention leur attention mais
tu te dois alors là pas du tout mais ce
à quoi le petit saut up
attention un patient au garage à part
les tribunes les gens calmes les gens
qui maîtrisent sa voiture donne des
leçons ça va d'un sursis et voilà il est
temps d'aller chercher quelqu'un qui a
un meilleur niveau que moi
vraiment extrêmement bien dévoué merci
tu te jure pas avec ce trophée de suez a
marqué quatre mario pour ce maillot m'a
laissé ses marques et malheureux l'air
pas trop apprécié juste confiance
mario mario oui la lune suite la
pastèque sur la tête c'est normal oui
c'est à lui qu'il faut surtout pas que
tu le touches sur site youtube est alors
assez incroyable mais alors attention à
la prison elle est où la prison à
l'émeute et deux dents cassées ou t2a
mais non à la sauce voilà l'enculé il
faut vraiment que tu meurs pour ford
accorde au message il faut se suicider
pour repartir de l'anglais la suite
attention ça ne se passe pas comme ça on
en rêve tous les enfants mais arrêtez
moi je me retiens à côté voir juste en
face bon oui attention j'arrête un saute
dessus à paupières surprendre voila
voila et là tu vas sur tuyaux vers la
haye a tout d'un piège mais on n'a pas
vu encore c'est bien regarder en garde
car bien réagi mais sans annoncer de
méchanceté tous pas des nuages hockey et
là j'ai 30 des mains ok peu de jus g
l'hépatite c tu débloques le cumin viser
tout comme tu étais dans l'après ça
croyez moi ça m'énerve c'est à cause de
lui
d'ailleurs je les regarde ta gueule il
m'a poussé dans le dos on a tout il ne
pousse pas d'appui dans tout c'est pas
bien nature et sa jumelle à l'écart
attention ça c'est facile
qu'est ce que tu dis pour rien je suis
médiocre alors il faut l'admettre
est ce qu'on appelle quelqu'un d'autre
en fait oui ok nature est il apte à
jouer on y va j'ai entendu ça t la joue
pas non mario götze plateforme way mario
kart
alors tu vois les choses folles la
course à m'élancer voiture 20 sauf les
cantonales bref on est désolé encore
parce que tu es tu fais environ un mètre
de plus que moi ces 16 millions mais à
la plus au nord
wolin a clamé pour prendre
[Musique]
les pièges par le passé au dessus c'est
un piège il s'est passé un truc
incroyable ici présent une gerbe
mais les filles malédiction
quelqu'un peut m'aider je trouve le
moyen de faire faire aux femmes le
ménage
je sais rien enfin c'est une pub mais
attends c'est pas parce que tu as déjà
visiteurs et nous sommes tombés
[Musique]
on a passé le niveau hockey ceci est
niveau de à toi de jouer
il faut rentrer dans le choc est là mais
du coup pour pas rentrer dans faut pas
que tu déclenché ce cul parce qu'il fait
son attention a pas déclenché le cumul à
champignons croyable on se sent paniquer
à gaujac way et là tu vas te wei est la
norme ans et kaia petit marshmallow qui
arrivent des patientes envoyé sur l'iss
non je suis toujours zen la joie six
mois mais des trucs bizarres qui tu as
tu échoues huawei va au bar et sautent
les salaires chercher là tu vas dessus
non c'est vraiment sombre être ok saute
dessus pour casser et redescend à gauche
voilà la tiba hall à la maison c'est moi
tu reviens en arrière vite sinon
d'atteindre tous
toxique et parce que tu es devenu
beaucoup trop un croissant de filles oui
oui je suis en voyage vers city
ambitieux jenny est ce que tu joue aux
jeux vidéo
en fait exactement ce qu'elle atteigne
témoigne ouhlala oui mais c'est foutu
faille pas si c'est bon tu as le génie
il faut toujours analyser avant d'agir
est la règle d'or je sais pas ce qu'ils
appelaient une personne à l'aide ne
suffit pas je pense qu'après une seule
fille en renfort ne suffira pas il faut
qu'on appelle des barjots et kara
comment ça va marion amis ma famille mon
petit chou
ben on n'y a pas getting over it là
c'est le but est simple tu dois avancer
et atteindre le prochain checkpoint le
checkpoint c'est le drapeau bleu comme
là où tu es actuellement tout à fait et
ba super et du fonds social parce que ce
que je disais c'est que je dois
énormément au jeu mais pas du tout à ça
j'ai bien hitman j'aime bien haut mais
c'est nul à chier tu analyses tu vois
comment vous faire pour que ça marche
qu'elle fait d'autres enfin
[Musique]
les amis déjà mais personne ne crie au
titre il a mis des filles oui c'est vrai
marjo je pense que tu es une excellente
pêche et la pire joueuse mais tu va
coacher caral qui a ajouté oui tu fonces
à droite n'ont su que ouais ouais là je
ne prends pas le poids
[Musique]
je sens pas au jeu sans pas alors le
deuxième check-point pas cette énorme
attend mais tu t'es fait un café en
scred mais c'est tellement poli
[Musique]
vous n'arrivez plus à donner l'énergie
est qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour
vous motiver
on habite tout heureux
non je dirais que je vous mets une mise
en garde si vous voulez je vous mets
quoi
[Musique]